happy holidays heather torres and sean
cannell here from think media and we are
so excited to bring you an announcement
about our youtube starter kit
yeah we have a special holiday promo
going on right now where you can get
over 90 off our digital asset bundle
that's going to help you start or grow
your youtube channel and if you want
help doing that there's a bunch of
really cool resources included in this
you can see all the details at
tubestarterkit.com
but it covers
a list of the best video ideas to either
start with or that you should add to
your channel that are going to get views
we've got a resource on 51 money making
ideas that's a lot of different ways
that you can earn money from youtube
we've got our best youtube title
formulas this is not just from the best
title formulas from think media or think
marketing but we've studied top
entrepreneurs and youtube creators and
distilled it down into a list that you
can just copy paste from to get more
views on your videos we've got our gear
guide with the best deals on gear that
you can get right now we've got our
create awesome thumbnails training which
is actually unreleased anywhere else we
actually go through the think media
process of making thumbnails we have
some photoshop training some lightroom
training but even some resources uh
special recordings from some of our
conferences that are unreleased and so
you get access to that too it's pretty
incredible it is called the youtube
starter kit but one of my favorite parts
of it is the youtube clarity blueprint
heather what's that all about the
clarity blueprint is your blueprint to
massively growing your channel why
because when you can break through the
noise and know who you're for and how
you're helping them and all the things
you need for your channel that's when
you'll start to see massive momentum so
i think sean that this is one of the
best pieces in this youtube
digital asset bundle yeah 100 any one of
these would absolutely be worth the
price that you'd invest in this but
we've made it absolutely affordable on
this limited time holiday special and
this is over 600 worth of resources it
normally is 97 but our holiday special
has it at 37
so if you want to take access uh get
access to all of this just go to
tubestarterkit.com
and you can check it all out our way of
helping you achieve your goals with
youtube this season and crushing 2021
you're gonna love it so check it out
tubestarterkit.com
start making better youtube videos today
with the youtube starter kit create
videos that get views and get
subscribers and ultimately make you
money for a limited time get 90 percent
off the youtube starter kit a power
packed digital asset bundle that will
dramatically shortcut your path to
creating or reviving your youtube
channel get it today for only 37
this offer won't last you'll get instant
access to the six resources valued at
over 630 dollars so head to
tubestarterkit.com and start creating
better videos today